wait i want to talk about the end of the
the second movie like you had the the
pubic beard
yeah and that idea came about because
we had a a writing session at jeff
tremaine's house
to come up with ideas for the movie yeah
and and i said uh
just in in this meeting i said hey man
for what it's worth
i uh like looked at my my
bush my pubic hair was just like such a
gnarly afro
like uh you had to i shaved it off
i shaved it off and it was so much
puberty it was such a big
bush like i stepped it into an empty
drug baggie
yeah like i did this several times
it's sitting in my uh in my medicine
cabinet in my bathroom
um and so we're like okay what can we do
with with pubic hair and and like
it the whole idea didn't come up in that
session but that was like the genesis
like
where it all came so you end up with
everyone's pubic hair yeah
super glued to your face which by the
way i would do that
i've said this every day i i i would i
i've said and i would really do every
day for like
i would say almost the rest of my life
have to shave off
your dick's pubic hair
off my beard then break my neck again
seriously so
[ __ ] movie and possibly all time of
jackass and i didn't have to break my
neck
i don't know dude they're done with the
carbs
the pubic beard the big beard was good
though because it was like but
aspect where aaron thinks he's pranking
this guy but that prank is all on him
like but
it was perfect but dunn's car up the ass
is probably
the best thing that's pretty much the
best thing yeah but the reason i bring
up the pubic
beard and and what the bit was called it
was called the terror taxi
with the pubic hair on your and then
like the the whole
terrorist bomb thing yeah and uh
you after it was filmed
you told everybody oh i knew it was
pubic hair i was just being a bro
i was just going along with it because i
didn't want to ruin the bit
but i knew okay you want me to tell you
the truth i mean this is this is a
controversy that's
that's raged on forever since the
beginning but since the beginning of it
he's got an answer oh i'm i don't lie
i don't need to lie why do i need to lie
about anything my life is so crazy
already
that whole time you and you absolutely
so i walked in this is huge so
i walked into train's office and he says
to me we're gonna film
and i don't care at this point i can
tell like anybody everybody and i've
told it
as verbatim the same way every time
because it's the truth
but i don't care to tell the whole world
now it doesn't matter i don't think that
you've told it the same every time
i have i've told it the same every time
that's the way it went down
no i didn't know about the pb okay so
check this out
so i walk in now we got another version
listen i'm going back to the beginning
of how i even ended up in this skit
i'm not at that time i didn't know there
was going to be any
hair involved on my face but i can tell
you this
that tremaine told me that he we were
gonna film the skit that i wrote
years ago and i went through all of my
notes when i got home because i write
everything down
and catalog it and i didn't find it
anywhere and i had already turned in
some
[ __ ] gold for this movie and it
wasn't being filmed so
i knew it was a setup i'm like i told my
girlfriend at the time i said
they're either going to pull a gun out
or a knife out or they're going to take
me i thought what they were going to do
is take me to jail and [ __ ] with me in
jail
and so that was where mine was my mind
was going so
when they're put in the pubic hair the
dick hair as i refer to
on my chin or on my face all over it
i even said is this pubic hair and and
it's in the film
i think it was i think they used that
yeah yeah yeah and and
and she goes no it's hollywood hair and
at that point i didn't even
process or give a [ __ ] because i
realized that what is happening right
now
is hilarious right so i went into the
taxi i didn't know his
channel c car whatsoever i should have
because he's
recognized but i'm sitting behind him
and dimitri's sitting next to me
and we're filming going to do this
[ __ ] gnarly terrorist taxi bit and so
i'm in character
saying take me through the brutal big
airport please and all those things and
and i don't know it's jay and dimitri's
looking over at me saying
like saying like hey hey say that one
and i said something
something that he had said to me and
then i started talking about
liking women's breasts and stuff and and
then
i'm like yeah we're going this way and
then all of a sudden we're
in a parking lot and jay gets out and
i'm like
i [ __ ] got a bum and why would i say
i've got a [ __ ] bomb it's totally
fake with the dude who's pointing a gun
at me
like do you think i would actually be i
know i'd be like dude i'm so sorry
instantly
so the only way out for me was to look
like a badass
and act tough and so i was like [ __ ] you
dude
i got a [ __ ] bomb what are you gonna
do and all this [ __ ] so you
you still thought this was not real
you knew it was a bit at that point you
didn't look like you knew it was a bit
exactly but i'm telling you the truth
okay
okay i knew what you're telling me you
can't process it's true
the same direction the whole time i knew
it was a setup i didn't know about the
pubic hair
i said this is pubic hair but then i
didn't even think about it anymore
because i want to stay in character
the whole time i'm being abducted all of
a sudden with the
he tells me to get out get on the ground
i'm in the back of the
[ __ ] taxi and i'm literally laughing
my ass off like under my breath because
i know i'm mike
and bam says something and i go that's
ben marcher he's famous
you should listen to him like you think
i'm gonna say that [ __ ] if i'm terrified
of my life
but i remember there's a point where
you're in the van and you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] stupid what the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i'm sick of this [ __ ] get me
out of here
that was fake no it was
entertaining okay so if i if i
understand correctly
you didn't know it was pubic hair glue
it was pubic hair glued all over my face
no that it wasn't a real taxi driver
i knew it was set up i knew it was a
setup the minute jeff told me that i
wrote the skit and i went back through
all my notes from all the last many
years
and couldn't find it when i knew that we
had already turned in
really great ideas and was wasting time
doing this what is this old skit i don't
i didn't write it
if i didn't write it but we're filming
it but he told me i'm writing i wrote it
then
it's a setup i don't know how it's going
to go down but i know it's a setup
all right so as soon as the cab driver
pulls the gun
in your head you know this is a bit uh a
prank on me
yeah so but then so you just
sort of play it for the camera like uh
the way you did it i
feel bad telling everybody all the time
over and over because especially they
don't believe me is one but it's the
truth
like i'm like it's not just a once and
for all because this will spark new
conversation of like
why why would you even say that it's not
true i'm like it is
it's just the truth it's how it went
down i am the one person that knows
understand
what you've explained so let's i didn't
know about
the pubic hair i knew it was somehow a
setup i didn't know how it was gonna go
down
my thought was and i told my girlfriend
at the time that it was gonna be like i
got a gun pulled on me
a knife or something like that or taken
to jail
where then i get [ __ ] with like leave
me overnight with cameras everywhere
and i'm freaking out that i didn't know
it was gonna stop there
and then when i come out and i'm acting
or i'm scared
whatever right right then they tell me
about the pubic hair and then that
processes through my mind like
oh [ __ ] like that's disgusting now
that i have a moment
to just take a breath and then i started
puking because it was in my mouth
where i had just ripped out a tooth or
something there were crabs in your mouth
yeah and then that that was all that's
all real
like come on man okay good was the dick
hair really that necessary
yeah and i made sweatshirts too that
said right yeah i like it
anyways it's called stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude